time again we have to break down all of
the fashion hits and misses from the
emmy awards last night so we have our
fashion expert back with us today
[Music]
frank marino is joining us to talk all
things sparkle glitz and glam welcome
back best subject to talk about oh and
you are the expert when it when it comes
to fashion now i want to talk about some
of the the hits last night there were
some beautiful dresses on the red carpet
and you selected your top ones and i i
this first one i agree with you amanda
seyfried yeah i mean i just thought she
looked so young and so fresh and uh that
the blush lavender pink was a big hit
last night for a lot of people having
that palette tone on there oh man it was
just and it fit her perfectly yes and
it's young you could wear a gown
sometimes it looks matronly but no she
picked the exact right one i thought she
was wonderful another one you selected
was rachel brazband she was wearing
pamela roland tell me why you selected
this one okay so not only do i love her
show but you could wear something
low-cut like that and it doesn't have to
be a vulgar you know what i'm saying
it's sort of like a share thing cher you
never see anything but it's very sexy
and i think she did it right in that
matter i i actually missed that one that
is really beautiful now another one that
you and i both picked lily james and
versace yes that's a stunner and you can
tell i love me sometimes i know yeah i
mean from head to toe come on now that
particular gown what i loved about it
it's all that metal mesh yes and uh you
don't see brown that often on on a dress
on an award show so it was so unique
that i just absolutely adored it such an
underrated color really it really looks
now this person who you were just
telling me she her life is like your
life basically in the show yeah it's
unbelievable jean's smart she's wearing
laura boshy
that's that really is beautiful the
draping on that yes and it's funny when
the show's on my every time somebody
will argue with her my sister look over
at me like did you write this show
and you said that she has your license
plate in the show yes and she's playing
my hotel and she is it they stole my
story
i love it
yeah exactly okay let's talk elle
fanning you should let selected her for
that's the best the best this is your
number one number one number one i think
she did a modern take on it marilyn
monroe still kept it young and fresh
it's cute and it was absolutely gorgeous
i would actually wear that in my diva
show any day she wants to drop it off oh
you could rock that i actually picked
zendaya too and i could see you watching
yeah and she was gorgeous too that that
would look really good for you
all right let's go to the worst dressed
here
uh i totally agree with what this pic
kaylee cuoco dolce gabbana yeah what a
nice looking woman and then that dress
the dress was wearing her and it looks
like at the bottom where that cutout was
like they just ran out of material and
just didn't finish the dress so for me i
didn't understand what was going on all
right so i usually love louis vuitton
but
you weren't really a big fan of sarah
paulson's louis vuitton now again i love
her as an actress but that dress and i
love louis vuitton yeah i never thought
i'd say this
needs to it looks like star wars or she
needs one of those light up sticks and
she looks like she's in costume to me it
looks like a costume that's why it did
now a big winner last night julia garner
and gucci not so much a big winner on
the on the carpet though huh i i didn't
understand this dress or all i know
about her is that she's gonna be uh
doing madonna yeah and uh i hope she
redeems herself when that happens i
think that cut out was what did it for
me that cutout was so bizarre um her
co-star in uh in ozark laura linney was
my selection i did the words
yeah what is it what do you think
actually i thought she had the dress on
upside down but
you never know what could happen at
those shows
frank where can people go see divas if
you've never seen this man in
his show it's so good
i'm at the tropicana every night at 7 30
except for tuesdays and uh we have cher
lady gaga adele and celine dion the
lineup's amazing all real women really
singing a lot of fun bring your family
it's family well except for me it's
family friendly i make it dysfunctional
family friendly but the same thing you
make it so much fun we love you frank
thank you